among farmers in india
anger is growing on monday
demonstrators in bengaluru the capital
of southern karnataka state
took to the streets denouncing three new
laws they say exposed them to
exploitation by private buyers of their
produce
and by big business protesters called
for a statewide strike
and burned effigies of government
officials
all the farming community will lose
their land
and be forced to become slaves of the
big companies
many of the bills passed by the
government the land bill
and regulations against the farmers and
agricultural produce marketing committee
will be
fatal to the farmers
india's agriculture sector makes up
nearly 15
of the country's 2.9 trillion dollar
economy
and employs around half of its 1.3
billion people
throughout the country the plight of
farmers who have struggled for decades
is a major political issue many are
heavily in debt
and suicides are common the governing
bartia janata or bjp say farmers are
being misled by opposition parties
and insist the legislation will help
liberalize agriculture markets
we as a party have decided that we will
move to every
hook and corner of the country and
educate farmers and this is the need of
our through this only farmer's income
can be improved
and this is the requirement
on the same day another demonstration
this one in new delhi
with police on guard the atmosphere
becomes heated
these farmers say their lives will only
worsen
but as many are detained they say
they'll carry on with their protest
mohammed al jazeera